Next up, we've
got Noah Falstein.
He's a man who kind of
needs no introduction,
but that would be a cop out.
So I'll introduce him.
I could say things
like Lucasfilm,
Lucasfilm games, or a man who's
made arcade games for arcades,
Commodore 64, Dos Windows.
He's done it all.
And now he's the
Chief Game Designer
for the Android team at Google,
whatever that could mean.
Noah Falstein!
Hello?
Give me a moment to make
sure I'm presenting here.
OK.
I assume everybody
can hear that.
Can I see a wave of hands if
everyone can hear me fine?
Excellent.
Alright.
Well, it's a real pleasure
to be here virtually.
I had hoped to
join you in person,
but unfortunately
the timing from GDC,
where I gave this presentation
last week, was just too tight.
But it's nice to
be back-- on, well
I guess both sides of the
pond-- for the moment.
So I've-- I'll
just dive in here.
This is a talk I gave last
week at our Google Developers
Day at GDC.
And it's an extended version.
That was only about
15 minutes and I'm
going to go into a
little more depth here.
I may not quite
take my full time,
but generally being a
little ahead of the schedule
is not such a bad thing
at these conferences,
particularly late in the day
as it is for you over there.
So I'll be talking a bit
about evolution today, which
is appropriate because,
as has been said,
I'm something of a dinosaur
in the games industry.
I started professionally
making games in 1980,
and in fact had dabbled
at university as early
as four years before that.
So it's a very long time making
games and very pleasurable
really.
I have no complaints about that.
It's actually kind of fun
being an industry dinosaur.
You get to pontificate and
GDC becomes a great reunion.
But I'm going to actually
go even farther back
than the dinosaur era, which
ended about 65 million years
ago with the asteroid
everybody has heard about.
In fact, I'm going to go back
to time around 540 million years
ago, something called
the Cambrian explosion.
And the picture
I'm showing now is
one of an artist's conception
of a lot of the sea creatures
that were found.
It was all sea
creatures at that point.
This was very, very
short in geological time
after multicellular
creatures first evolved.
And as you can see, there
are some really strange ones
out there.
In fact, pretty much
every single one
that has been found
in the Burgess Shale
where most of these
fossils came from
is just bizarre and
creepy to our eyes.
You can't quite see the details,
but one of my favorite ones
there is a little fellow who
has five eyes and a long tongue
that ends in a claw, and it just
looks like something somebody
did on some sort of drug trip.
In fact, one of these creatures
is named Hallucinogena
because of that.
At any rate, the
point I want to make
is that pretty
much as soon as it
was possible for
multicellular life to spread,
it spread into just
a wide profusion
in every ecological niche.
And that's a lesson that I
think has a lot of relevance
for us, because it
spread out, there
were many different
types of creatures.
And then perhaps it
was another asteroid,
perhaps some other kind
of disaster wiped out,
I believe, about 80%
or 90% of those life
forms in a very short time.
And then the ones that
remained evolved, spread,
moved into new
ecological niches,
and eventually also came out
on to land and became us.
This kind of rise
and fall of eras
has happened many
times geologically.
And in fact, it's very similar,
I think, in a lot of ways
to what we've seen in
the games industry.
I'm old enough to remember
Pong when that was new,
and even before that Nolan
Bushnell's Computer Space
game that I thought
was the coolest thing
I'd ever seen when I first was
a teenager going into an arcade.
I was expecting mechanical
pinball ballgames only,
and suddenly here was
this sleek cabinet
with this wonderful-- well, I
should draw a picture of it,
but you should
take a look at it.
It was well ahead of
time, and in fact he
went to do Pong afterwards
because it was so far
ahead of its time, no
one was ready for it.
And that's a lesson we
can learn from as well.
But just as with the
physical evolutionary rise
and fall, we've seen that in
the games industry many times.
And when I was
doing arcade games,
I worked on a game called
Sinistar many years ago,
and within a year of it
coming out, almost 90%
of the audience for arcade
games had just given up.
It was a very quick fad that
faded, and happily consoles
and PC games quickly
rose to take its place.
Recently, we've had
similar kinds of us
and downs with the social
revolution and 100 million
people playing a
game on Facebook
or on other social services.
We've had that same kind of
rise of indie developers.
I asked this at
GDC and nearly 2/3
of the audience considered
themselves indie developers
of one sort or another.
Just a few years earlier,
that was quite a rarity.
And of course, we've
seen with the huge rise
in mobile coming almost out
of nowhere over the last five
years or so.
I have friends who were
working on mobile games
10 or 15 years ago, struggling
in the era at that point,
before-- much like the
Cambrian explosion-- suddenly
smart phones made it possible
to have all sorts of great games
out there.
So, what does that bring us to?
Well, this is a cliche, but the
Chinese character for crisis
is made up of the characters
for danger and opportunity
together.
And it's just a
wonderful metaphor,
and I'm going to deconstruct
that a little bit.
I think it's still
quite relevant,
even if it is a bit of a cliche.
First, what's the
danger involved?
Well I think the real concern
is that a lot of things
are coming to an end.
I talked about cycles, and
it's easy to talk about cycles
from a calm,
long-term perspective.
But if you're the
dinosaur caught up
in an extension as
this fellow here,
who's actually just
about half a mile
from me over that main buildings
in the Google campus here,
then it can be a pretty
terrifying thing.
And really a lot
of people believe
that this might be our
last big console cycle,
that the PS4 or the Xbox1,
these are-- that we're never
going to see a big expensive
dedicated console again.
Personally, I'm not
quite sure of that.
You know, one thing that
my experience has taught
me is that it's really hard
to predict exactly what will
happen, and we've been
surprised many times before.
And yet I have to agree that
there are many reasons why
I think that's a possibility,
and personally I'm
a bit relieved not to
be betting everything
I have on not only
the next consoles,
but on one particular console.
That's always a really nervous,
nerve wracking place to be in.
And I'm sure some of you
have experienced that.
Another thing that
concerns a lot of people.
I talked about social games
having 100 million users,
and largely a lot of users
have moved over to mobile now.
And even mobile seems
to be getting crowded.
The future for that is
also a little bit murky.
But there were many
of my friends who
were at Zynga and
Playdom a few years ago,
and virtually all of them
have left those companies.
In fact, most being made
redundant at some point.
So it's pretty scary
to see that coming,
and to-- being and seeming
like the big new thing,
and then within
just a year or two
have it seem like
the yesterday's news.
It's a very scary
thing that way.
Some other dangers.
The cost for mobile development,
as with almost every new area,
is climbing.
Competition's quite
fierce, and it's really
driven up the
lowest stakes there.
If you really want to
compete in a mobile game now,
you need very high
production quality,
and of course that means
longer time and more money
to produce things.
It is still possible, you
get your little Flappy Bird
successes that-- little in
terms of development costs
and big in terms of
income-- but of course,
that becomes rarer
and rarer when
you look at the huge
numbers of people
trying to get into
that industry.
So that's a bit of
a cause for anxiety,
if not necessarily
doom and gloom.
And it's not all
technology or game type,
it's also the business
model that's been disrupted.
Free to play surprised a lot
of people, myself as well,
in not just that
it was successful.
It didn't surprise
me that it was
one possibility that
worked quite well.
But just like the four limb
model of humans, and primates,
and for that matter mammals,
amphibians and birds,
you know, so many
of our creatures
have pretty similar
kind of structure.
And it seems that free to
play is likewise spreading out
to become by far the
most popular way to do
mobile games these days,
at least for monetization.
Similarly, digital
distribution and rentals
are causing a lot
of people concern
and opening up
opportunities for others.
So none of this is new, but
you take it all together,
it's pretty scary.
And there's also, of course,
an ever increasing choice
of hardware.
Just so many different
platforms out there in addition
to the big consoles and PC.
You now have
microconsoles, you have
lots of head-mounted
displays, everything
from full virtual reality that
we've seen from Sony or Oculus
Rift, to gadgets like this one
here that are becoming popular.
It's actually amazingly
stylish around where
I am at the moment.
So let's move on to some of
the positive side of that.
There's really a lot
of opportunity as well.
I think the way to look at this
is that boundaries are really
breaking down everywhere
at this point,
and that can be a scary
thing, but it really
opens up lots of new territory,
lots of new possibility.
So to start with, I
don't think we've ever
had a more lucrative time
in all of my history.
Certainly, the industry is
making more money as a whole
than it ever did before.
As early as about
10 years ago, people
were trumpeting that games were
finally making as much money
as movies, and usually they
have to compare the best games
to studio box office, and not
talk about video rentals or all
the other ways that the
movie industry cashed.
But increasingly, it's
just becoming simply true
that games are more lucrative
than film, and not only that,
but show every
sign of continuing
to spread if you look at games
as a whole, combination of all
of the different types
of games out there.
It's also, and I think this
is even more encouraging,
never been more
popular and widespread.
You know this is a
matter of global reach.
I travel a lot.
I really enjoy speaking
around the world,
and it's amazing to me how even
tiny countries with population
of 1 or 2 million
people sometimes
have 2 or 3 different game
development companies in them.
And of course, many
other places like the UK
or the US that have been
doing it a long time,
it's just hard to count the
number of small and even
medium and large
developers out there.
So lots of widespread
development.
Lots of widespread game
playing, and not just
in terms of where in the world,
but also who in the world
is playing.
We have younger people playing
in some times than ever before.
Tablets certainly have
become a huge thing with kids
even younger than 2 years old.
And brain games, an area
that I work in some,
is becoming increasingly
popular with people
in their 70s and 80s.
You know, areas that we
never really expected
were going to be big
for game playing,
and yet have become quite
vital in some areas.
Japan, I think, at the height
of some of the Brain game boom
had over 80 different types
of Brain games on the market,
and many of them
were quite popular.
It's also, as I say with
Brain games, increasingly
consequential.
One of the things that I've also
done before coming to Google
was work in the serious games
or games for impact area,
where the games have a purpose
besides just entertainment.
And there's nothing
wrong with entertainment,
I think it's a great
purpose in itself.
If anybody, by the way, ever
is making games that are fun
and feels a need to kind of
revitalize their enthusiasm
for just doing
something that's fun,
I'd recommend a movie
called Sullivan's Travels
from the 1940s.
I'm just curious, I can
see most of you there.
How many people have seen
this movie Sullivan's Travels?
Anyone?
OK, it looks like not many
hands, and not surprising.
1940s films aren't
that popular, but I
used to work with a
fellow named Hal Barwood.
We created Indiana Jones and
The Fate of Atlantis together.
And Hal as a filmmaker, actually
co-wrote, as a ghostwriter,
Close Encounters of
The Third Kind and
worked on half a dozen feature
films that I quite enjoy.
So he told me about
Sullivan's Travels.
It's a black and white
film, but a really good one
if you're feeling a
little bit in need
of encouragement about fun.
And yet, beyond fun, games
are helping certainly
in the medical area, they're
helping diagnose and treat
people with brain
injury and trauma.
They're helping train
surgeons and medical people
of all types.
But beyond that,
there's training
and social interactions in
games that are helping people,
for example, with autism
learn how to better interact
with their peers.
Lots of really exciting
games out there.
I'll be speaking at the
Games For Change conference
next month about
some of these things.
So that's pretty exciting.
And we've never quite been
so connected in so many ways.
There are more and
more screens out there.
I've got lots of tablets at
home-- of course, some of that
is just because Google tends to
shower us with devices to test.
But even before I
joined the company,
they were starting
to proliferate.
And we're also connecting
in different ways.
This is a picture from
a project I worked on
with Dr. Adam Gazzaley.
He was doing a game
called NeuroRacer
that I had a small hand.
Recently, it got on
the Journal of Nature,
a very prestigious
science journal.
First time that the
journal-- actually, I
think any major
science journal-- has
had a video game on the cover.
But it's proven
to be a great way
to actually improve
people's ability
to multitask while driving.
Not driving and
texting, but being
able to drive and
also see road signs
and respond to those
sorts of inputs, which
tends to deteriorate
as people get older.
And yet with game
training, it's shown
that not only can 70 and 80
year olds get back to the levels
that they were when
they were 20 or 30--
and this is measured
through a combination of EEG
that you're seeing
there, and fMRI.
But they also retain those
gains six months later,
which is just quite
remarkably, even
without playing
the game anymore.
So a lot of things games are
doing to both connect directly
to our brains and
also to help people
in really consequential ways.
We've never been on so many
different devices and screens,
I mentioned that before.
Google has also announced
initiatives for wearables,
for an automotive initiative
to plug Android devices
into displays in cars.
Of course, Google
Glass, and there
have been announcements
of watches coming out
in the near future.
All of this is
really in our future.
This has actually been a
really useful device for me.
I started testing
it, and have been
amazed at how handy
is to have around,
and there's some really
fun games that our New York
office made that are
on there as well.
And, so what else?
Games have never really been
analyzed in as much depth
as they have by universities
all over the place.
So we really
understand how games
work, how they affect our
brains, how games have evolved,
and how we have
evolved to want to play
from even pre-history,
before we were human.
Anyone who has puppies
or kittens at home
can see that play is a way that
young of many species learn.
And in general, I think
this is a positive thing.
But of course, it can
cause some anxiety
as well because I've
just talked about all
of these exciting things
and I'm willing to bet
that the large majority
of you have only
focused on one or two
of these different areas
with all these new
technologies coming out.
There's just so
much out there now,
it's pretty much
impossible for anyone
to go into any depth across
the whole breadth of all
these things out there.
So what can you do?
Well, again I like to take some
cues from physical evolution.
After the dinosaurs,
as we all know,
a little mammal starting
with shrew-like creatures
like this little fellow
here, proliferated,
grew much larger, moved into
various ecological niches,
and in many ways
were able to spread
much farther than dinosaurs
did, and certainly
deal with a much wider range of
temperatures and environments.
And that's happened, as
I said, over and over
in the games industry.
So what we can learn from
that is if you're flexible
and you embrace change,
it's a winning strategy
pretty much every time.
In fact, the whole
cliche of dinosaurs,
if you think about
it, is sticking
with the same sort of thing,
getting bigger and bigger
without regard to the fact that
you're getting more vulnerable,
even as you're getting
more powerful sometimes.
So another point, though,
is that even though I'm
using this analogy, we can
actually change much faster
than actual physical
evolution that takes place
over millions of years.
We don't have to wait to
have the fittest survive.
We can see something
that works and graph
those changes into
our games, as has
happened with lightning rapidity
for things like free to play
pricing, or the
growth of social,
mobile, any of these trends.
We're actually getting
faster and faster
at adopting new
trends, and I think
that's very encouraging,
because being
able to be as flexible as
that is a really good thing.
And Google, I think,
is in a great position
to help developers with this.
I don't know of any
other company that
is involved in as
many different things
and, as I'm sure you've seen in
your presentations there today,
this company is really committed
to helping game developers.
I've been with the company
for about a year now
and it's been a
real pleasure to see
how much game development
was actually going on.
Sorry about that.
Should have shut those down.
How much game development
is going on at Google
in many different ways,
but I've been getting
involved more and more
with all sorts of new ways
that Google is
getting into games.
And games are one
of those things that
can spread through every
type of technology.
And as you can see with a lot
of the presentations you've
seen today, Google is into
helping at every stage,
from the early
production and research,
to understanding how
to build the games
and giving you support
for Android, Chrome,
you know lot of different
platforms out there,
all the way through
getting out it there
getting, getting
your game recognized,
and getting it monetized
through advertising
or whatever method is
that you choose to use.
Google is into so
many different things.
And as I said, I think every
one of the things that I've
got listed up here
has game potential.
And I'm with a group, by the
way-- our name within Google
is the Fun Propulsion Labs, and
you'll be hearing more about us
in the fairly near
future-- but we're
very interested in the range
and breadth of what Google
is interested in, and
seeing if we can apply games
to many of these
different areas,
as well as help you, the
game developer community,
by making our tools
for game development
as good as possible.
So, I'm going to conclude with
a little bit about the future.
I hesitate, as I said before,
to be too positive because there
is no one future.
One of the things I've learned
about the games industry
that I love about it,
is that there are many,
many different possible futures.
This is a wonderful
industry if you're
open to change and
reinventing yourself.
And they're just--
you never get bored.
There's always new stuff
coming out, and never more
than in the last few years.
In my 35 or so years
in game development,
this is just an
extraordinary time.
So here are some suggestions of
what I think will work for you.
You need to be open
minded, because it's
so hard to see where the
next hit will come from.
You need to be willing
to adapt and see
what new trends there are.
And that's easier to
say than it is to do.
Sometimes it's hard to tell the
difference between a fad that
will burn out quickly
and a new trend that's
coming along to stay.
For example, virtual
reality was a big topic back
in the late '80s when
I first experienced it,
and the technology just
wasn't quite there yet.
It's coming on very strong
now, and it feels to me
like it's going to be
very solid this time.
And yet, I know
of a lot of people
who get physically ill when
they put on a virtual reality
unit of even some
of the best quality.
So, hard one to bet on.
But, stay open
minded means that,
hey even if a third of
the people can't use it,
that still leaves a
huge number of people
out there who might
find it very worthwhile.
Think globally in
all senses of that.
You know, certainly in
other parts of the world,
there's huge growth
in Asia in particular.
I expect places like Africa,
places that we don't really
anticipate these days
as huge game market,
but that could grow to become
them in the fairly near future.
And also in established
markets, there
are sometimes new blue
oceans of new technologies
that are going to spread
and become very popular.
When you see how smart
phones have taken over
in Europe, and the US, or
really all around the world,
from very quick beginnings
not that many years ago.
You don't want to discount
even established markets
for having mew areas to go into.
And personally, I would
suggest each of you
look to compete in
areas that you're
strong in, that you are good at.
Each of you out there, I'm
sure, has your own abilities,
your own strong points.
Some of the stuff out there,
as attractive as it is,
won't be right for
you, for your company,
for you as an individual.
And other things will
be perfect for you
with the background you
have, the interests you have.
Go with your passion,
go with your interests,
and go with your strengths,
and it's hard to go wrong,
even if there is a
downturn in the industry.
If you've done something
that you're good at,
and that's you're
proud of, then I
think that you'll
be in good shape.
And hand in hand
with that-- this
is a really strong
philosophy here at Google--
you want to be
agile and iterative.
It's important, I think, to
fail fast, to try new things.
We see this on the
game design side
all the time with
paper prototyping
and other fast
computer prototyping,
as by far the best way,
instead of coming up
with a detailed plan,
a 100 page design doc,
[INAUDIBLE] of that design
doc, and then consider
whether this is
actually any fun or not.
That really doesn't
work, you really
need to be agile and
iterate very quickly.
And in a similar sense,
you want to diversify
as much as is practical,
even if it's just
a little bit, because
sometimes teams are small
and they can't afford
much diversity.
But better to have one
main thing you're doing
and one small side
project that could
grow than to only put all
your eggs in one basket
and be stuck if that basket
drops and you're out of luck.
I know of a lot
of game companies
that have gone under
because they bet everything
on one throw of the dice,
and often through a funding
change or some circumstances
totally beyond our control,
it didn't work out well.
The companies that have had
several things going on at once
are the ones that, much like
the little mammals going
into new slots, new ecological
slots, were able to succeed.
Another thing that I would
say that I've learned here
at Google and is
definitely true, is
don't bet against the Internet.
I was skeptical about some
always online, multiplayer
concepts because of times that
I would travel and be on a plane
without internet.
And a recent
international trip I had
was the first one
I went on where
they had internet
available the whole time.
It's getting harder and
harder to find places
where there isn't good
internet availability.
And even if you can still
come up with circumstances
where that's a problem
now, it's a pretty good bet
that in the future--
probably the near future--
it will increasingly become
less and less of a problem,
and speeds will go up as well.
So taking advantage of that
is always a safe thing.
And finally, I'd say Google
really wants to help with this.
This is a company that
I'm very happy to say
can benefit indirectly.
We don't have to focus so much
on the kinds of direct revenue
models that I was used to as
an independent game developer
because it helps us if the
whole industry prospers.
And we hope that we'll be
able to help you prosper,
because it'll really
be the rising tide that
helps all boats, if I can
add one more cliche in there.
So that's it.
This is my contact
information, my email address
and Twitter feed.
I'm also happy to connect
with people on LinkedIn,
but please don't send
a generic response.
Just tell me even if it's
simply that you saw me
through this
presentation, that's fine.
And I don't know if I'm
equipped to take questions
at the moment, but I don't
think there's much time,
so let's cut it off at that,
and thank you very much.
Thank you very much, Noah.
It was great that you
could join us here today.
Thank you very much,
and we're intrigued
to see what comes out of
the Fun Propulsion Labs
when you make your
announcements.